bienvenue dans l'entretien de france 24
nous sommes avec l'un des esprits les
plus vifs du continent africain il est
historiens politologues et philosophe et
depuis trente ans il réfléchit à la
marche du monde le camerounais achille
mbembe est notre invité achille mbembe
merci de nous rejoindre sur france 24
depuis johannesburg où vous vivez et
enseigner
mais c'est vous qui vous remercie alors
l'année dernière vous avez été mandatée
par le président français emmanuel
macron pour penser le nouveau sommet
afrique france assommée centré sur la
société civile nouveau afin d'oeuvrer à
la refonte des relations
franco-africaines votre implication a
été néanmoins largement critiqué neuf
mois après quel bilan tirez-vous de
cette participation
c'est un bilan extrêmement positif la
preuve demain
13h heure de paris
sera signée seront signés à
johannesbourg en afrique du sud les
statuts de la fondation pour
l'innovation et démocratie en afrique
cette signature intervient moins d'un an
après le sommet de montpellier
cette signature marque
l'entrée en mouvement de la toute
première recommandation qui étaient
contenues dans le rapport que j'avais
soumis au président de la république
parallèlement
le travail en vue de la construction
apparaît même de la maison des mondes
africains deuxièmes recommandations
[Musique]
ce travail est en cours
et où je vous parle d'une consultation
internationale
organisée justement pour recueillir les
avis notamment déjeuné au sujet 2 du
concept maison de la façon dont elle
sera gouvernée
alors avant de rentrer dans les détails
achille mbembe tout de même vu eu la
violence des critiques que vous avez
reçus est ce qu'avec du recul vous
regrettez d'y avoir participé certains
disent quand même que vous auriez été la
caution des manuels macro la caution
intellectuelle africaine d'emmanuel
macro qu'est ce que vous répondez
mais je n'ai pas répondre à des idées
des sottises je vous parle de
réalisations concrètes qui ont suivi le
sommet
je pourrais y ajouter le travail en
cours
dirigés par piloté par l'historienne les
la dri et qui concerne la mise en place
d'une étude études avancées en afrique
et d'un campus nos marques qui profitera
à des milliers d'étudiants et chercheurs
africains et dont on est passé à la
phase de l'action et je pense que pour
le moment
le bilan il est positif nous avons ces
camps pour mettre en place l'essentiel
des recommandations
cela vaut bien plus que du zoo les
soeurs de bavardages
que l'on observe ici là et alors se
fonde la démocratie
certains s'interrogent justement sur la
pertinence que la france le prennent en
charge justement parce que tout
simplement la france cautionne aussi et
soutien
des états et des gouvernements sur le
continent africain qui sont pas très
démocratique quelle légitimité la france
at elle pour finalement accueillir se
fonde la démocratie
le fonds d'innovation pour la démocratie
n'est pas une décision française elle
est une institution africaine française
e européen c'est une co-construction
et de ce point de vue et inaugure la
nouvelle génération d'outils dont la
france aimerait
se doter de pour effectivement engagé
cette tâche de refondation de ses
rapports avec l'afrique mais le score
par la france on peut en réalité de
l'europe
c'est des rapports aux africains qu'ils
voudraient parler et de rock tout cela
me paraît absolument positif malgré tout
assez le mb l'image de la france malgré
tous ces efforts six ont pu dire l'image
de la france c'est quand même largement
détériorés notamment au sahel
comment vous l'expliquez et que peut
faire la france finalement pour changer
ça j'ai publié un texte dans le magazine
jeune afrique qui décrit les selles que
tâche des reculs si déjà pelé qui
attendent le présent la république c'est
cette tâche aux peu les revisiter si
vous voulez mais il faut par exemple
accomplir un pivot stratégique du point
de vue des interventions militaires sur
le continent point de vue de l'existence
des bases militaires sur le continent
négocié un nouveau contact avec les
africains à ce sujet il faut
qu'ils ont amené jusqu'à sa conclusion
finale la réforme du fonds s'est enfin
il faut relancer surtout la recherche au
sujet de l'afrique parce que elle évolue
beaucoup plus vite que les connaissances
que nous en avons et on a quelques
propositions de ce genre qui sont
réalisables
on peut réussir si vous voulez est alors
une des promesses de la politique de
d'emmanuel macron du président français
ça a été de changer la narrative entre
le continent africain et la france est
en cela vous aussi vous êtes d'accord
mais est ce que vous vous estimez que le
président français a réussi cette partie
là et quand bien même est ce que
véritablement ce qu'on appelle la
françafrique vulgairement est ce que on
peut dire que c'est révolu ça n'existe
plus
c'est un concept dépassé qui ne rend
plus compte des transformations qui sont
en cours et sont en cours depuis un bon
moment la vérité au fond c'est que la
france ne peut plus à elles seules
changent le cours l'histoire africaine
ou en tout cas certains pays africains
cette phase est terminée
historiquement rend dans une nouvelle
phase c'est une frappe c'est que pour le
moment on est au milieu du gué on a
quitté les rivages françafricain on
n'est pas encore arrivé au bout du
chemin 1 et donc sur boxer on n'a pas
encore de nom pour le nommer ce mois ci
le tâche de construire ce passage qui
m'intéresse d'un point de vue
intellectuel et d'un point de vue
politique je ne suis pas le seul présent
n'est pas le seul dijon dans cette
entreprise
et parmi vous
justement vos batailles il y à empêcher
les jeunes de déserter le continent
africain pour aller se jeter dans cette
émigration clandestine est allé en
europe qu'est ce que vous leur dites
finalement à ces jeunes parmi vos 13
recommandations vous en avait parlé il
ya aussi la dimension des étudiants et
un amant de choses qui sont prévues
qu'est ce que vous leur dites pour faire
en sorte qu'il reste justement sur le
continent africain
je ne veux redire ils doivent décider
d'eux mêmes de leur destin et du destin
de l'afrique le destin de l'afrique de
ce point de vue dépend de la capacité
dont nous ferons preuve
d'ouvrir la fécane elle-même
d'intensifier la circulation intra
africaines de transcender les frontières
que nous avons héritée de la
colonisation en construisant chine ou
des conditions d'une vie décente
créant chez nous les institutions dont
nous avons besoin pour dix ont
relevé au niveau de vie et je plaide en
faveur de la construction d'institutions
transfrontalière je le fais depuis des
années je pense c'est la clé pour
répondre au désir de fuite ou de
recherche d'une vie meilleure
qui taraude les jeunes générations leur
avenir c'est en afrique
alors leur avenir est en afrique se font
pour la démocratie signé le 7 juillet
justement va se déployer ceux ci on a
bien compris sur plusieurs pays ça sera
pas un institut ni un fonds qui sera
uniquement placé en france si je vous
entends bien mais nos aînés déjà et
n'est pas placé en france le forme
d'innovation pour la démocratie a son
siège en afrique à johannesburg en
afrique du sud il disposera de trois
axes régionaux en afrique de l'est
afrique orientale
en afrique centrale je te dire les pays
de l'arc atlantique du bassin du congo
jusqu'aux
grands lacs et un arc occidental qui
recouvrira le sahel de sa ra et la
méditerranée et d'ondulations
panafricaine qui couvrira toute
l'afrique qui s'occupera en particulier
de l'animation l'intelligence collective
proposant de ce fait un ensemble de
parcours pédagogique ciblées et qui
s'intéressera à la recherche mais pas
seulement fondamentale mais je suis à la
recherche hachey
l'objectif étant de relancer l'agenda
démocratiques sur le continent africain
merci on vous a entendu merci beaucoup à
celle membe d'être venu sur le plateau
de france 24 merci beaucoup c'est ainsi
que s'arrête cette entretien rester avec
nous car les programmes continus sur
france 24
[Musique]